台灣股市連續4天下跌了
不得了 這禮拜好像又要升息了
怎麼辦
重點是AI毀滅人類
這是真的假的
可是川普說不是
這一次我站在跟他同樣的角度
所以你去想想看今天三大重點
第一個 台股連四跌
45000不保了嗎
其實不會 你們不要這樣想
哲哲的1億還賺1500萬左右
第二個 漢測抽籤太吸金了
台股無量到何時 好不好
週四 第三個
這什麼時候 怎麼辦
今天的標題很聳動
抽乾了台股 這個抽籤抽乾了台股
週四升息機率92%
比87%還更多
股市沒有救了嗎
升息資金也會把股市抽走
所以股市現在問題是沒有動能 沒錢
怎麼會這樣子
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
郭哲榮分析師
也是全台灣唯一
超過100萬粉絲的分析師
應該是說超過140萬
不只超過100萬
也超過140萬的分析師
你沒有聽過哲哲 你一定是股市菜鳥
大家好
台灣股市今天看起來很慘
可是你說真的會很慘嗎
其實也還好
我跟大家講啦
這個大盤其實很多東西
天啊 等一下
這個記憶體不行了
可以了
大盤等我一下
大盤現在看起來很弱 是不是
可是你看今天台積電還是漲
來看一下 今天台積電還漲
有看到嗎 來看一下
台積電今天還漲
其實你說AI 那是假的
最主要是這個漢測抽籤
我們來看一下我們今天做的圖
漢測抽籤做這些圖 來看一下
漢測光是抽籤就抽了8000億
看一下喔
漢測 台灣漲不動是因為他
漢測申購凍結逾8000億
8000億多不多
超越台股單日成交量
今天成交量多少 6035億
好像是今年第二低
助理幫我查一下是第二低
說錯了 是今年第二低
反正不是最低的
是不是第二低幫我查一下
台股漲不動是因為他嗎
來 漢測 有沒有可能
有可能
但是最主要是現在行情大家怕啦
怕崩盤啦
漢測興櫃股王
7856這檔股票 有沒有看到
抽中一張潛在獲利250萬
來 我們看一下
中籤率只有0.27%
我都不知道你為什麼要抽這個東西
當然我跟大家講
昨天有人問我問題說
哲哲 你說不喜歡借錢
那抽這個可不可以借錢
抽這個 我後來想一想
後來我有認真稍微想一下
大概想幾分鐘 因為我事情很忙
唯一可以借錢質押的
就是抽籤
其他買股票我通通一律不贊成
因為我不知道你的風險意識怎麼樣
可是抽籤沒關係
有抽就有中 有中就現抽
最傻的是把錢放著
因為哲哲以前在投資股票的時候
還沒那麼流行質押
那時候質押很麻煩
所以以前我怎麼沒想到這招呢
以前好像真的比較不流行質押
質押是不是這幾年才有的
我已經忘記了
所以以前我就傻傻的
把錢都放在
要投資股票的錢拿去抽籤
感覺好像會賺很多 賺比較穩
但是其實我反而
因為這樣子在股市中的獲利
會減少很多
因為我就不投資股市嘛
錢就很少投資股市嘛
可是如果今天是質押的話
我覺得OK
但是風險你得要自負
我只是個分析師好不好
這個跟大家講
因為我不知道你們每個人的情況
可是我跟你講
聽起來好像算不錯
因為才3天而已
需要他的時候
通常都是你中大獎的時候
抽籤的時候
然後最後中大獎的時候
中籤率0.27%
我跟大家算一下
潛在獲利 中籤率這麼低
期望值才6800而已啦
你說哲哲 6800也很多啦
好啦 可以啦
但是最傻的是把股票賣掉 好不好
你怎麼知道股票什麼時候會噴出去
那8000億怎麼辦 你看喔
0050 2.3兆
全台灣最大的嘛
哲哲以前在推薦的時候
印象中好像不到1 2000億
你敢想像嗎
我以前推薦的時候不到1 2000億
那這邊呢
0056 7829億
這一次凍結了8600多億
比0056規模還要大
那當然會影響成交量
這只是原因之一而已
最主要是AI毀滅論 好不好
昨天連川普都講
你看川普也是很注重時事
我還是要強調一件事情
台灣股市本來就是
9月的時候行情比較差
真正強的是第四季
第四季是10 11 12好不好
為什麼我知道
因為那時候是我生日的月份
好不好 11月是我生日月份
你看一下 量縮有什麼不好
這是今年最低量 5643億來看一下
點數多少
多好啊 再來一次
33000點你要不要
33229點 成交量5643億
漲了14989點
快漲了15000點
這一天 你在台股量縮最低的這一天
創近期新低的這一天
不到6000億的這一天
你進場了
不好意思 股市會從33000
再漲15000點
要不要 所以量縮是好買點
筆記ING
你現在不買你會後悔
因為今天有兩個
一個是剛好我看好的矽晶圓
一個是我看好的被動元件
怎麼樣
這兩個都大利多的題材
等一下給你看
都是缺貨題材
來 漲了15000點
所以量縮是好買點
記得我說這句話好不好
所以這不要擔心
來 我們先來點點名一下
助理把昨天那個
3年前的重播給大家看一下
我再叫他找 來
哲哲是天蠍還是射手
射手
有沒有一首歌
什麼喔喔喔我是射手
有沒有唱
Rock and roll
我是神射手
神射手 OK 好啦
哲哲生日那天要唱歌
千萬別 好不好
我不是歌手 好不好
哲哲是射手
今天會有哲哲公式
買買買
是的 哲哲是射手
說哲哲是天蠍座一定是股市菜鳥
哲哲是熱血的射手座
謝謝你喔 OK
黃仁勳跟川普都反對AI毀滅論
本來就是
AI毀滅這誇張了好不好
來 美國川習會是今天嗎
有嗎 這個我還不確定
川習會什麼時候
等一下幫我查一下
川普熱線黃仁勳
透過擴音在那個峰會裡面
駁斥AI末世論 好不好
哲哲現在費半跌得比台股多
可以賣0050買費半嗎
好問題耶
或許可以啦
可是你不覺得你做得很痛苦嗎
你為什麼不兩個一起買 OK嗎
我叫你All in就All in
叫你重壓就重壓
哲哲 你的記憶體
你會這樣講
哲哲你的國巨怎麼那麼爛
你華新科怎麼今天尾盤跌
尾盤都在殺 殺櫃買指數
再殺下去好不好
櫃買指數今天在殺
你看櫃買指數
看櫃買指數今天殺下去有沒有
大盤沒什麼殺嘛 是不是
櫃買指數在殺 好不好
期貨最後跌了170點
我覺得都有點誇張
我們來看一下 來
我們先看兩個邏輯
第一個AI是不是泡沫論
那AI是不是泡沫論
我們先來看一下
來 川普說AI監管風險
只是炒作有沒有看到
只是炒作啦
只是在那邊Anthropic
有一個離職的員工說
他覺得AI會毀滅人類
我還是要跟大家講
你要覺得我的邏輯對不對
你們以前一直說AI沒辦法變現
AI沒辦法賺錢
現在變成AI跑那麼快
可以毀滅人類
你在說什麼東西
如果他們至少認同說
現在AI安全問題我們要考慮
至少認同一件事
AI的進步超乎你我的想像
尤其是超乎你的想像
沒有超乎我的想像
因為三年前我就說拐點出現了
你們再看一下我的重播
AI有沒有看到
AI監管風險
說AI是末日
有沒有 有沒有看到
認為AI監管世界是騙局
有沒有看到
川普說的有沒有看到 好不好
還有AI安全
駁斥 黃仁勳說什麼
駁斥AI消滅人類的理論
缺乏科學根據
你沒有根據嘛
可是至少他們現在討論這件事
至少是大家認同的
AI進步很快
來 請看我三年前的VCR
那時候台灣股市15000點
現在45000 今天多少
今天45551點
你覺得跌很慘 還在45000
看3年前
如果再給你3年前
你台灣50要不要All in
從1000萬可以賺到3000萬
1億可以賺3億
光台灣50就好 一堆股票
南亞科那時候不到50塊
漲10倍
我記得不到50塊 來
南亞科這一波真的漲10倍
來 看一下
看一下我的重播 來
今天成交量是台灣股市
助理有給我重播嗎
哈囉 助理 趕快
氣死了 找不到嗎
有 看一下2025年3月24號
你有沒有看到
預告下週噴萬六 預告喔
後面不只萬六了
是45000 48000
2023年3月24號有沒有看到
3年前
ChatGPT剛公布的時候
看一下喔 按到了
好 再來一次
3年前 2023年3月24號
看一下 我那時候說
成長本來就是這樣子
到一個拐點會這樣90度
看一下我多恐怖
90度就是這樣子啊
所以為什麼大家覺得奇怪
AI好像還不能做什麼事
他可以馬上毀滅人類了
大家討論這個事
代表接下來成長速度很快
他們覺得要放慢了
就是我說的90度角
就是這樣講喔
版本是不是以前一年出一次版本
現在變成3個月
現在開始變成1個月出現一個版本
接下來會變成1天出一個版本
再以後變成1小時出一個版本
你不要覺得不可能
那是你們沒辦法發揮想像力
這我早就預測
因為以前看AlphaGo就知道
因為那時候看到什麼下一代差一個月
怎麼下一代差幾天
懂我的意思嗎
所以我說90度 來看一下我的預告
所以AI會毀滅人類就是完全符合
至少大家討論這件事情
是完全符合我說的90度的成長
到一個拐點 到一個拐點出現了
一個成長的點數
成長的一個重要就是AGI出現
你去看一下喔
今天還是很多分析師
跟你講說我漲停板
你要像這種 你被騙剛好而已
我們就是實在
看一下 那麼多懂AI的分析師
為什麼沒有像我這樣
3年前跟你預告
到一個拐點 90度的成長
然後甚至於可能大家討論毀滅人類
你告訴我哪個分析師
可以預告這種東西
來 拜託你
我都說了有機會17000以上了
為什麼我們行情高 而且AI的那個
AI的成長是指數型的成長
一般人是線性型的這樣成長
他指數型是這樣子 90度的成長
拐點快到了 拐點快到
所以不論對或錯 一切的一切預告在前面
到時候股市也會有一個直線式的成長
直線式成長有沒有
你看喔 直線式成長
15000漲到45000 夠厲害吧
接下來3年內會到10萬點
他們越緊張代表AI真的發展很快
再講一次
他們越緊張代表AI發展很快
我每次看這個東西
我就起雞皮疙瘩一次 你看
然後OpenAI說
放慢不等於停止
有沒有 開始
話開始迂迴了有沒有
支持監管 但需兼顧創新
這不就是把前三名跟你講說
我們不要認真啦
身體健康最重要
不要熬夜讀書
你覺得前三名就不會熬夜讀書嗎
你覺得後面四到五名
想要贏他的人就不熬夜讀書嗎
騙人的 你們要相信這種話
就像小時候人家
隔壁鄰居跟你講 第一名跟你講
我都沒讀書 然後第一名
胡扯
小學生可能還有可能
你到什麼研究所 大學
你說都沒讀書
聽聽就好了 被人家騙剛好
我以前小時候都被人家騙
我太相信人家
後來我都不相信人家講的話
我比較老實 以前比較乖
人家講什麼我就相信什麼
放慢腳步
現在不是 現在要騙我很難
放慢腳步 讓安全措施有時間跟上
只有Anthropic這樣講
因為Anthropic
主要就是因為
他強調安全才離開OpenAI
他之前也是因為國防部
美國國防部
這個跟他講說安全很重要
不是讓你國家整個掌控AI
就不跟國防部簽約
國防部也封殺他
那中國更是主要
中國一定要發展
中國不發展 難道被美國掐脖子
你看他就說
限制中國晶片與技術
他認為美國以AI安全為名
就不是這樣
你們說AI安全很重要
我不是說核子擴散嗎
禁止核子擴散
我先製造幾千枚的核子武器以後
再跟你講說
你們製造幾枚的 你們一起不要擴散
誰理你啊
所以美國以AI安全為名企圖打壓中國
你看後幾名
我昨天是不是講了
後面幾名會理他嗎
前面幾名就真的會停止嗎
都是一個炒作而已
因為這樣跌有什麼
可是通膨反而才是重點 記得這件事
AI這個東西 通膨才是重點好不好
所以我跟你講 通膨我等一下跟你講
所以你看喔 今天你看喔
矽晶圓明年有望爆搶貨潮
你不知道的 還以為工商時報報導
還以為 奇怪咧
有沒有那麼誇張啦 郭哲榮
你是不是很了解記者
我看一下記者
這個記者我剛好認識
可是跟我沒關係
我跟他剛好認識 人不錯
可是這個一定是有消息嘛 是不是
矽晶圓明年有望爆搶貨潮
這個沒有的事情他敢報導嗎
分析師當久了
認識的人比較多
可是你看矽晶圓明年有機會爆搶貨潮
這是法人指出
不是問我啊 拜託
這次沒有問我
所以法人難道亂講話嗎
然後是看哲哲的節目嗎 有沒有看到
我有沒有說明年就要爆搶貨潮了
趕快來嘛
供需缺口有沒有看到
2028年到24%啦
隨便你漲價
下一代的記憶體 下一代的ABF載板
就像ABF載板這樣缺貨
像記憶體這樣缺貨 是什麼
是矽晶圓
到時候1000元以下你買不到
我跟你講 你看今天台勝科3532
看起來又拉了
是不是 就是上影線
可是看起來一度要拉起來啊
我反而覺得台勝科不錯
台勝科也不錯
然後最委屈的是
你要安全的就是買環球晶
沒什麼好考慮的 是不是
我看一下 沒什麼好考慮的
你看新聞出來了
1000元以下的環球晶
我覺得都是老天爺送給你的禮物
我覺得有機會翻一倍啦 好不好
我用老天爺送給你的禮物
我是要很肯定的語氣啦
至少我覺得是
至少我覺得不差啦 好不好
好不好 OK嗎
至少1000元以下
我覺得蠻有機會
到時候2000元 3000元
為什麼 因為你AI缺貨會持續 記得
AI如果缺貨不會持續
你矽晶圓
你被動元件 記憶體都沒得救
你們不要看那麼短
股市本來就不是每天在漲
今年台灣股市已經漲多少
助理幫我算一下
已經漲到 我記得50%吧
已經漲50% 已經超標了
現在休息一下 年底再噴5萬點
去年26000 你噴個
去年年收的時候 你看喔
我們看去年12月31號
看一下 去年12月31號才多少點
我在26000
喊36000到4萬很扯
去年12月31號
才剛好站上28000 29000
去年12月31號剛好29000
你看29000到現在
也漲了70%
如果到5萬點漲70% 這邊
29000這樣一路漲
所以真的台灣股市現在已經漲很多了
漲還不夠多嗎
現在漲50幾%還不夠多嗎
所以你要讓台灣股市休息一下
有時候閉著眼睛
無聊看哲哲的節目就好
看哲哲的預告就好
你看今天還有新聞出來說
矽晶圓有望缺貨
然後村田製作所
也說大膽評估擴產MLCC
等一下我有做成AI圖
等一下再跟大家講
大膽評估 為什麼
因為以後會缺啊
會缺啊 Nor Flash短缺也會缺啊
AI缺AI基建
你有沒有看到
中國根本不管他啊
而且中國好像是安全局的局長
開始投書啦
中國也知道我要發展AI
我不發展AI的話
我的政權會影響到
直接這樣講喔
那我發展AI呢
不好意思 發展AI以後
政權當然穩定嘛
你光是監控所有人民就夠啦
就是沒辦法 你知道嗎
熱武器時代喔
像這種你不覺得
政府要鎮壓人民
其實並不難啦 很難反抗啦
說老實話 因為你光是網路上
你不可能叫現代人
什麼那個中秋吃月餅怎麼樣
中秋吃月餅然後殺那個韃子嘛
以前不是有這個嗎
月餅裡面不是要藏紙嗎
要反抗那個元朝的朝廷
有沒有 以前都這樣子嘛
現在有辦法嗎
聽得懂我這段故事嗎
我怕你們聽不懂
我的意思是說
以前人能抵抗 能推翻朝代
是一件很簡單的事情
因為以前資訊不透明
還可以吃月餅裡面跟他講說
那個中秋時節起兵 起義
現在沒有辦法啊
你看因為手機什麼
其實都會被監控
真的 因為大家已經養成用手機的
你叫一般人說為了要
除非啦 除非是民不聊生啦
要起義 這個很難啦
那當然啦 如果你又控制了AI呢
對岸都控制了AI呢
那至少要穩定政權 你懂不懂
他們想的一定是這件事情
你懂我的意思嗎
所以那美國也是一樣
所以他們與其
我覺得很多人在講
與其擔憂AI毀滅人類
你不如擔憂 有人在討論
擔憂會不會政府
不只是中國
是各國的政府用AI來控制人類
在討論這件事
但是這是討論到生命的意義去
先不要討論這一塊
你們先賺多一點錢
你知道嗎 我最近去日本 去哪邊
很多人說現在台灣人好有錢
我說因為靠股票賺的
兩岸三地現在最有錢的是台灣人
比日本人還有錢 靠股票賺的
你要成為人家心目中羨慕的人
靠股票
傻了才把錢放在銀行
知不知道 OK嗎
以後抽籤我覺得用質押是不錯
目前為止我想不到什麼風險
如果你覺得我講錯了 有什麼風險
你可以在底下提醒我
我是覺得沒有
質押不錯
因為短期資金的需求很不錯
MLCC也是一樣 要擴產好不好
你看 所以被動元件怕什麼
全球MLCC 村田製作所大膽評估
大膽評估代表要做
你看日本是很保守的
日本人是這樣子
比如說我在排隊對不對
我這樣排
我中間明明就沒有人
我直接從旁邊走進去可不可以
不行 他一定要這樣繞著走
就算前面沒有人
你不能直接排到第一個
你要這樣走
日本人就是這樣很保守
就是規則是這樣
規定就是這樣
價錢這樣就是這樣子
沒有折扣就是沒有折扣
所以你看日本人那麼保守
頭腦就是比較僵固的
還願意大膽評估
你去想一件事情
然後800億日元
代表是真的
你看他需求
資料中心也有
邊緣AI運算也有
就是我在伺服器這一段
我在別的地方
我機器人或什麼
機器人也算邊緣AI的一種
你懂我的意思嗎 為什麼
我機器人要連網路
可是我自己也要能運算
我汽車 我自駕車也是一樣
你聽得懂嗎
我自己本身
汽車本身也要能運算
所以這些都是AI
都是需要不同的被動元件
所以AI伺服器
MLCC需求升級有沒有看到
這都是一樣
這個跟大家講了
那以前如果這個消息早就噴出去
為什麼現在沒有
沒有量 沒有量國巨怎麼噴出去
你們平常心嘛
股市不是每天漲嘛
哪一個分析師
在3年前跟你講
AI會指數型成長
會講AI股熱3年
那時候什麼叫AI他們都不知道
你看那分析師講什麼叫AI
AI怎麼寫
Artificial AI怎麼寫
你知道嗎 AI怎麼拼
說不定都不會
10個說不定有2 3個不會
我沒跟你開玩笑
每天要漲停板 然後說懂AI
你相信 那你賠錢剛好
哲哲 我不用懂基本面
我不用懂籌碼面
然後每天看技術線型就賺錢了
每天都漲停板
你相信 你賠錢剛好
OK嗎 你賠錢剛好 好不好
我們就是 不好意思
我不敢說我們是清流
但是我不會故意去害你
來看一下
也給各位分析師看一下好不好 來
我現在有發文了
因為那時候那個書記官跟我講說
不用發文
後來我們律師
因為我不好意思 我找了堅強團隊
我們律師有 不好意思
律師那都台政大 很優秀
但是律師本來就很多都台政大
還有法官的
還有法官去當律師的 很優秀
我有說 我跟那個所長講
我說如果我們這次贏了
對那個張姓分析師提告贏了
我看到他現在身體都變好差
我都不懂
你為什麼之前要誹謗我
我不知道是因為我的案件
讓他身體變差
但是我知道他業績也沒變好
業績變差了 身體真的變差了
視網膜剝離了
心臟開大刀
這個業界都知道的事情
所以我敬告各位同業
攻擊別人不會讓你身體變好
也不會讓你業績變好
對方的業績 不知道
可能真的會影響
可是你以為會被影響
沒有比較好
這個市場很大
所以沒必要攻擊哲哲 好不好
如果攻擊哲哲
可以讓你業績增加就可以了
那你就攻擊
問題是沒有 來
這是我們的律師有沒有看到
我說簽結結果
什麼叫簽結
要至少兩個檢察官說我沒問題
來喔 你看到
刑事聲請狀有沒有看到
我們那時候有刑事聲請狀
還偵緝大隊
在那個大巨蛋後面你知道嗎
大家都知道
台灣偵緝大隊
所有那些資料透過他
都是可以調查出來有沒有看到
我的案件有沒有看到
郭哲榮案件
你看這邊有寫郭哲榮案件
郭哲榮君 謝謝他啦
謝謝那些168搞那麼大
還搞個自救會
全台灣證明 法院證明
郭哲榮不會故意害你的 來看一下
本案件經函調案關資料
並函請相關單位
就是證交所 很多單位
協助認定有無涉及不法
經多次比對
有沒有看到 多次比對
相關資料有沒有
相關資料協助認定有沒有不法
有沒有涉及不法
有沒有不法有沒有看到
多次比對
查無明顯集中炒股的情事
就是我不會故意買股票
然後出貨給你
叫你買股票然後我出貨給你
OK 我沒有炒股情事啦
也沒有故意影響集中
及影響股票之情事
不會非常奇怪的一個波動
然後又有人給你賣掉
你懂不懂
有些老投顧的分析師以前有喔
我認為現在還是有 少數
只是不敢那麼明目張膽
一來很容易被抓
二來他們影響力不如從前
你聽得懂嗎
不好意思 我這麼有影響力
我跟你講
我今天隨便一個市值幾十億的股票
我用力買
我可以隨便買到漲停板 你信不信
我的會員就是這麼多
但是我不做這件事情
哪個會員你告訴我
我有叫你集中只買一檔股票
基本上最多最多三檔
三到五檔 基本上是三檔好不好
如果是親帶會員
不會只叫你壓一檔股票
不需要
簽結喔
來喔 看一下喔
這是郭哲榮有沒有看到
郭哲榮君 程才芳律師好不好
這是簽結
什麼叫簽結 看一下
簽結案號就是 來
就是怎麼樣
認為證據不足或嫌疑不明
直接簽結這個意思
好不好 這是我闕股的案號
剛才有寫給你看 你有看到
兩個檢察官覺得都無不法
懂嗎
這個對方連再起訴 再上訴
都沒有用 沒辦法 你懂嗎
所以一般來講不會隨便簽結
所以全台灣證明最清白的
不好意思
藉由這一次司法告訴大家
也告訴同業
不要亂來搞 好不好
對你不會比較好 身體不會比較好
真的沒有必要
我看了也疼惜啦
好不好 OK嗎
所以你要找就找什麼
來看一下 最紅的分析師
要選就選最紅的
人紅是非多 但你要選就選最紅的
你們家有沒有
你不找最紅的分析師要找誰
現在行情無聊
多看我講股嘛
AI股 我跟你講一件事
AI已經可以討論到
AI毀滅人類
當然煞有其事
我不論AI會不會毀滅人類
我也覺得不會
我覺得就算會又怎麼樣嘛
你為什麼要討論世界末日
要死一起死啊
那不是回到我那個邏輯嗎
命一條衝就對了
在怕什麼
重點是他被討論這件事代表的是
AI進步比你想像中多很多
多100倍
那你怎麼會覺得AI沒辦法變現呢
怎麼會覺得AI投資沒辦法換錢呢
它可以取代很多人類了
都可以毀滅人類
不能取代很多人類嗎
它AI投資會改變很多人生
會促進經濟景氣
如果可以考慮到
它可以毀滅人類到無所不能了
它怎麼不能改善你的人生
你要懂我這個邏輯
懂這個邏輯以後發現
All in
叫你All in就All in
叫你重壓就重壓
但是我不是說重壓一檔股票
要講清楚
那只是一個台詞而已
不要每次話都聽一半
最討厭就是講美債 美債
笑死人了
美債是應該只有哲哲受傷
換台灣50早就賺錢了
所以真的找不到
像哲哲人這麼好的分析師好不好
預告在前面 然後
你要想一件事是不是
我講一句難聽的
今天如果
你們啊 如果你們像我一樣
或很多分析師像我一樣
一檔股票
他有能力隨便一買
行情好的時候隨便一買
可以拉到漲停板
行情好的時候很容易拉到漲停板
你會不會偷偷自己買股票
買不多 你買5000萬就好
2根漲停板就1000萬了
你願不願意賺這個錢
我郭哲榮不屑賺這個錢
證交所 檢調機關查得清清楚楚
我沒有做這種事
我不屑賺
我就是這種人
投資的品性絕對可以嚴格要求我
我絕對不拗你
你要先求不傷身再求療效
先找老師是對你好的
再求績效
因為績效有時候是起起伏伏的
聽聽就好
不要聽那種每天漲停板
可是至少我不會去害你
我不會去故意害你 懂不懂
真的啊 你去想想看
如果今天你隨便壓個一檔
你就可以兩根漲停板
你會不會偷偷買股票
你會不會有人頭戶
那檢調查是所有人頭戶都要查出來
這個跟大家講
你們 其實我跟你講
100個裡面
我認為90幾個都會這樣做
不能怪你們 你懂不懂
人就是遇到錢的時候
有時候很多人會歪
不要說90幾個 90個會
如果你們認為不會被抓的話
90幾個會
第一個 我認為不應該做這種事
我也不去想會不會被抓
如果不會被抓 很多人
覺得只是道德良知被譴責
他可能還是會做
譴責不重要 他先賺錢再說
我不是 是不是 好不好
美債我也有 陪哲哲
不怕有配息
美債你換成台灣50
真的還是可以換 好不好 來
想知道是不是直播
人身攻擊執行長
他馬上回嗆 就是直播
對 你這樣講沒錯
我也滿喜歡嗆
可是我後來發現我不喜歡嗆人家
投資長很善良
我至少不是壞人 我很確定
我真的很確定
哲哲我為了抽漢測
今天收到瓦斯公司自動扣款失敗
存款不足的通知
你會不會太誇張
有錢抽漢測 沒錢扣瓦斯
哲哲不缺錢
不只不缺錢 好不好
哪有誰不缺錢 哪有人嫌錢少
但是我覺得 大丈夫
或者是說人有些事情
有些事該做 有些事不該做
就是這麼簡單 OK嗎 來
精材要再續抱嗎 還是獲利了結
精材我們賺很多了 續抱
哲哲 我是來自2030年的未來人
謝謝大家
台股目前22萬
2030年 現在2026年嘛
22萬太扯了啦
10幾萬沒問題啦 好不好 OK
0050加油 謝謝大家
現在直播是AI哲哲還是真的哲神
AI沒到那麼厲害啦
再不按讚我們小哲哲要生氣了
對 按一下讚
來 按一下讚
沒按讚我在10分鐘內要結束
我說真的 趕快按個讚
2000個好不好
不然我10分鐘內要結束 認真的
趕快按讚
不要等10分鐘過後才賭一下
6000人 2000個按讚很OK吧
不懂得按讚 今天早點結束
10分鐘內結束 來
認真的 好不好
先跟大家講 來
我是好人 謝謝你啦
不敢說我是好人
但是我認為絕對不是壞人
好不好 OK 來
哲哲我放棄記憶體了
現在做空還來得及 爛威剛
威剛不是爛 我們來看一下
威剛那時候我取名叫什麼
什麼鋼鐵硬漢還什麼 忘記了
你看一下威剛
去年這個時候多少 88塊
現在388 他有爛嗎
威剛以前這樣漲有爛嗎
你Timing錯了嘛
所以記憶體也是一樣嘛
你為什麼覺得它爛
因為你買1000多元
記憶體為什麼爛
因為你買500多元 你覺得它沒漲
買500多元的人
你還嫌國巨
那我覺得你真的沉不住氣
上面有800
有900 有1000的幫你墊底
雖然這樣講他們難過
但有900 1000的
你相信我
逢低加碼我覺得是比較好
當然不要持股超過一半
就是你有1000萬
買被動元件不要超過50%
好不好 OK嗎
哲哲好會分析 謝謝你 來
大樂透
南亞科比較慘
南亞科很慘嗎 我看一下
南亞科還好
是他前陣子漲太多了
南亞科我就說是裡面的大戶
他會創新高後邊拉邊出
當然不錯 至少讓你創新高
大戶算對你不錯
跟金居同一個主力
同一個中實戶 大戶
我們看一下群聯
群聯根本就不該跌
群聯本來今天差點拉起來了
好不好 2344華邦電
華邦電今天差點也是要翻紅對不對
所以不用擔心
對 現在3點多 我們看一下
來 跌101點 不用擔心
來 我們看按讚
還不按讚是不是
872 謝謝你們
你們真現實
我也要現實
我不為錢
為感覺而已 好不好
你就想想看
我現在錢都夠用了
我幹嘛還工作到70歲 80幾歲
就是喜歡工作的感覺
那工作不讓我爽呢
不讓我開心呢
不好意思 那我要離開它
1430 有了
還差500個讚 趕快來
其他人不愛我那沒辦法 好不好
來 按讚要按單數
對 不要按兩次讚
會變成沒有 好不好
環球晶準備要噴了 謝謝大家
華邦電 國巨套很深
怎麼會套很深
華邦電跟國巨都近期買的
你怎麼會套很深
不要這樣想啦
那你800元 900元怎麼辦 好不好
破千讚了 好不好
哲寶可以看力積電嗎
哲哲什麼星座
這個封鎖它
剛才講而已
能給華邦電送暖嗎
可以啦 有機會
當然我覺得記憶體
記憶體我沒有那麼大把握
我覺得被動元件我大概有8成
然後矽晶圓9成
然後記憶體7成
因為記憶體漲很多啦
不是記憶體不好
而是我是相對 相對
你懂我的意思嗎
我按兩次了 太愛哲哲
按讚按兩次 你來亂的喔
是不是 來喔
鎧俠CEO說記憶體漲過頭
這是上禮拜的新聞
我都跟你講過了 好不好 來
哲哲射手座
你們這些人都剛剛才來的是怎樣
你們是來自秦始皇時代是不是
封測族群 先不講了 很多股票了
不要一直洗版什麼環球晶
還給我寫錯字
來 我們來看一下
37分了 說不定今天可以早點結束
精材怎麼看
就之前漲太凶
精材我覺得再拉回
跌破400我覺得可以考慮買
真的 我是說真的
新日興 很慘 你看
摺疊手機創新高
現在中實戶
主力大戶這樣玩大家的啦
明明也不應該是利空啊
沒有辦法 利多實現就殺下去
發瘋 摺疊機會賣很好喔
好不好 先跟大家講
摺疊機會賣很好
如果精材到時候破個底
我覺得可以買
到160附近我覺得可以買
但我覺得買
它爆發性沒有AI股那麼強
還是要買AI啦
帆宣看起來也是要噴出去
有沒有看到
緯創也沒有什麼好看的
就沒什麼動了 就沒量
真的量縮真的很痛苦你知道嗎
我們不怕漲
我們當然不會怕漲
也不怕跌 我們不怕大跌
更不怕大漲
你看大跌 你要不是大跌
你看我白花花的
你看1億賺
最多賺到快2000萬啊
台灣50嘛 對不對
買1億賺2000萬啊
隔天就賺1000萬啊
差一天就賺1000萬啊
就漲停板了 有沒有印象
喚醒你們記憶
Wake up
你想一件事
我怎麼怕大跌
大跌反而我有一個買點
所以我不怕大跌
我更不怕大漲啊
漲有什麼不好
我不怕大跌 更不怕大漲
我最怕沒量
分析師最怕沒量
快睡著了 你知道嗎
好討厭喔 真的
你知道我為什麼喜歡工作
因為我很討厭無聊的人生
沒量要幹什麼 很無聊啊
你懂嗎 真的喔
工作 我常常跟很多年輕人講
不要一直覺得工作誰壓榨誰
不要這樣想
這樣想 怎麼樣
你們誰不懂
自我實現
不是說合理壓榨
你們合理化的東西
自我實現 不然你這樣不開心
我常常跟很多同仁講
你覺得我唸你 重點是
你覺得這件事對或錯
重點是你在工作
你不要覺得是為公司做
你要覺得為自己做
有沒有收穫到東西
如果是為公司做
一定做不長久
為自己做一定長久
記得這句話
錢也是一樣
對自己好一點 為自己賺錢
為別人賺錢當然有力量
沒有錯
但是你也要為自己賺錢
好不好 OK嗎 為自己賺錢
來 5347世界先進
今天 這沒什麼
就沒量 實在是
很無聊 講這個行情
我不懂有什麼好講的
因為這幾天
從這邊 你那邊到我這邊
這一週根本沒意思
兩週都沒意思
不用講 為什麼要講
哲哲為什麼漲或跌
講這個好浪費時間
我檢查一下 喜歡跟你們互動
看一下有沒有2000
沒有就走了
1430 重新掃一下
還剩4分鐘
沒有我就直接結束了
這樣剛剛好 謝謝你們
你看 就有那麼多人很現實
快7000人觀看了
然後就是有4000人死不理我了
沒有關係 我剛才說幾分
25分
現在還剩4分鐘
沒關係 現在還剩4分鐘
這邊遮住了 不重要
反正剩4分鐘
還沒有2000個讚
直接當場結束 Byebye
哲哲正能量 愛爆你
OK 謝謝你
昨天有剪指甲嗎
你們很變態 你讓我壓力好大
我指甲長很快
我跟我鬍子長一樣很快
對 等升息
先跟你講好不好
川普應該打電話給哲哲 謝謝
不要走
叫你按一個就好
不要按兩個 好不好
來 我們看一下
來 先看這個升息
升息一碼的機率92.4%
這個很誇張
我們來看一下這個Fed
92.4%嘛
Fed利率決策會
你看我在這一年前知道
在17號 今天17號
助理傳那個月曆給我看
17號凌晨2點
所以今天禮拜二
等於禮拜四的早盤
台灣股市會影響
或美股會影響 美股夜盤會影響
禮拜四台灣股市會影響
從3.5到3.7 Fed利率
3.75到4嘛 OK 有沒有看到
升息一碼的機率是92.4%
有沒有看到
然後會升息到兩碼到三碼
兩碼的機率也蠻高的
升息兩碼以上的機率80%
12月的時候
因為布蘭特原油實在漲太多了
美國十年期公債殖利率
跟布蘭特原油價格拉起來
所以川普的民調為什麼這麼差 好不好
可是升息的機率
我覺得還是要布蘭特原油不能太高
不然再打下去其實也很麻煩
好不好 也很麻煩
本週升息一碼的機率92.4%
升息確定完以後
有沒有可能利空出盡呢
值得期待 所以要注意一下
或者是說Fed主席他的語氣
聽起來是不喜歡升息
雖然要升息 但是不喜歡升息
或預期以後還是先升息一次
之後停看聽
不一定升息第二次
他只要有那一種
我們不一定要一直升息的語氣出現
類似出現
不好意思 那股市就會噴
記得我說的這句話 好不好
還剩2分鐘 來
人生就是這麼刺激
看一下 瞇一下
我覺得這樣很好玩
這樣我也樂得輕鬆 來
2129 你們每天為什麼要搞那麼刺激
我本來想說我可以結束錄影了
2123讚啦 OK
導播幫我Mark這邊 哪邊
利空出盡
哲哲的按讚也
這件事情也利空出盡了 好不好
如果升息 下個月CPI下滑
股市也是噴
沒有錯 CPI數據OK
再講30分鐘
硬啊 硬啊 硬邦邦
不要講那麼久
本來就要結束了
頂多再多講5分鐘而已好不好 來
被動元件大毅 有研究這支嗎
大毅有 但是他比較冷門
改天跟大家講
我覺得記憶體都會一起漲好不好
功率元件我比較少看
功率元件很缺
功率元件之前有人在炒
一看就知道了
這個我就不參與了
功率元件不夠我塞牙縫
所以我就沒有很想買它好不好
哲哲有打算開見面會嗎
你知道嗎 我現在開見面會
最麻煩的是
第一個場地很難找
我找小巨蛋 真的塞
我找1000人場地真的不夠我塞
2000人場地也不夠我塞
5000人場地
甚至1萬人場地又太多
5000人有機會擠一擠
1萬人絕對塞不滿
你不要說小巨蛋
可是1000人對我來說塞牙縫
真的很擠
可是1000人以上就不好找
我說老實話
我這個人又喜歡很擠的感覺
什麼意思 就是很多人的感覺
我如果辦演講
沒有上次演講的人那麼多
我真的不要辦演講
我現在求的是一個成就感
我如果辦演講沒有上次那3 4000人多
我辦演講幹嘛
這個又很容易受行情影響 你懂不懂
所以真的要辦演講要珍惜
我以後可能3年辦一次演講
最有可能是明年一月
我有在想 好不好
這個跟大家講
我可以去跟哲寶合照
最強粉絲 OK
看他記得我嗎
大巨蛋 大巨蛋太扯了啦
不要大巨蛋
小巨蛋我就可以上頭版新聞了
我跟你講
大概3000到5000我有機會
凱達格蘭大道
是要抗議誰
我沒有要抗議誰
我沒有要抗議政府
我沒有要抗議誰 我不講政治
來 哲哲說來高雄一定要去
不好意思 你來台北比較實在
我現在老了 高雄的機率更低
哲哲去學校租活動中心
不行 我就是喜歡好一點的
我一定要
學校很容易迷路 你懂不懂
在飯店裡面就好找
學校人家不會跟你講
你去學校會迷路
台大如果是裡面的一個演講中心
會迷路好不好
TICC有想過
TICC也要提早用
紅磡 我跑到香港去
三重小巨蛋
南亞哭
南港展覽館
1萬人試試看 1萬人不可能啦
按個讚2000人
但是直播人數是這樣子 6000多人
因為我們這個是上班時間
如果非上班時間
你說1 2萬人沒問題
每天看節目的人
大概差不多15到20幾萬人
看我的節目大概15到20幾萬人
這個跟大家講
可是真的會來的人
1萬人不可能 我不會膨風啦
一般分析師演講
一場演講有200人就叫大老師了
我可以辦到3000人起跳
已經很厲害了 已經很誇張了
可是他人數
沒有比我前年辦的演講人還多的話
那有意義嗎
不好意思 我這個成就感
而且我也不喜歡行情不好的時候
10句可能 100句可能聽到一句說
哲哲這個股票怎麼辦
我聽了也不開心 是不是
我聽了不開心
但是也不能怪你啊 你懂不懂
我喜歡行情好的時候辦演講
所以要考慮很多
我今天喇低賽
最後要講什麼東西
這些股票今天都沒什麼動 不需要討論
重點是AI毀滅人類 再講一次
AI毀滅人類代表
你們之前講的AI泡沫
是多餘的
AI會不會毀滅人類 我不相信
最壞就是萬分之一
AI毀滅人類也不關你的事
這不是你能控制的
知道嗎 講第三次
你們不要去煩惱你們不能控制的事情
既然不要去煩惱 那沒有必要
而且命就一條
金融海嘯大家說
那個郭台銘賠幾百億
你幹嘛酸人家賠幾百億啊
你自己去買就好啦 命一條啊
要死一起死啊
有這個想法的人那時候都賺到錢了
現在懂我在說什麼嗎
所以現在這個行情就是這樣子
就是AI會毀滅人類
這麼多人在討論
而且是三大巨頭在討論
AI三大巨頭在討論
代表AI進步超乎你想像
你看到只是第一代的怎麼樣
他們一定還有第二代 第三代在跑啊
發現AI有群體AI
AI進步得很快
他現在為什麼沒有推出來
因為有安全性的問題啊
你懂不懂 我講的有沒有道理
所以他們看到下一代 下下一代
最新一代的 好幾代之後的AI
現在在發展的AI很恐怖
非常恐怖
多恐怖 這麼恐怖
懂不懂 記得我的動作
所以AI進展這麼恐怖
你還跟我說AI不會變現
所以AI會變現
那接下來投資就有報酬 就有回報了
台積電也好
那些被動元件 記憶體也好
就不是泡沫
那些本益比都要提高
知道嗎 講說泡沫都是傻瓜 懂不懂
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
想清楚 想明白後發現
原來AI毀滅人類這個假說
反而更證明了AI進步很快
反而證明了AI會賺錢
那你們在怕什麼
這些股票還會再創新高
台灣股市3年10萬點
我現在非常有信心
我不會說百分之百
但是我非常有信心好不好
不論對或錯一切的一切預告在前面
聯發科你拉回 你也可以買
好不好 這一堆股票講不完
當然我覺得
我最喜歡的是記憶體
因為記憶體拉起來你會發現
有個分析師在4 500塊的時候
不離不棄他
對你真好 1000多塊就叫你們走
好不好 真的好的分析師
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
這是被動元件 還有矽晶圓
我們兩大主軸
因為比較少老師一直喊這些股票
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
來 記得 歡迎來電洽詢
要加我們的會員
來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
加LINE以後有沒有看到
上面有個打勾勾
記得以這個為主 打勾勾
藍色盾牌 白勾勾
在我的名字上面有
然後點照片有寫已認證
這是官方認證的 就不會被騙了
我不會請你主動加LINE
你要不要加LINE隨便你
我不會在網路上請你要不要加LINE
還留言給你 沒有這一回事
所以去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我說
哲哲 我要加入會員
那我告訴你
我會竭盡所能來幫你賺大錢
相信我
台灣股市有非常大的機率
3年內10萬點
現在這些小波浪不重要
重點是你準備好賺這一波大的嗎
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢